Salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche c'est le jour des explications
donc je vais expliquer des choses.
Le thème de cette vidéo d'explication est : comment forcer un nombre ?
Pas n'importe quel nombre...
On va voir comment forcer un nombre à 3 chiffres et un nombre à 2 chiffres.
Je vais d'abord le faire sur vous, mais il y a une règle !
La règle, c'est qu'il faut que vous admettiez que ça ne marchera pas forcément par caméra interposée.
Déjà, parce que je ne vous ai pas en face de moi
c'est pas forcément les bonnes conditions.
Ensuite, parce qu'il y a qu'une règle mais elle est longue
parce que vous vous attendez à ce que je vais faire, je l'ai déjà annoncé
donc vous n'êtes pas en bonnes conditions pour vous faire forcer quelque chose puisque
vous attendez à ce que je vous force quelque chose.
Et enfin parce que le taux de réussite n'est pas de 100%.
Pour le premier, c'est parti !
Vous allez me regarder, et à partir de maintenant vous allez penser à un nombre à trois chiffres dans votre tête.
Il faut que tous les chiffres soient impairs
et il faut également que les 3 chiffres soient identiques.
Vous avez un nombre à 3 chiffres, identiques, impairs, maintenant et c'est 333.
Ce forcage là fonctionne extrêmement bien.
J'ai jamais eu d'échec dessus.
Suivez exactement, le mot à mot, le script que je viens de dire avant.
Ça parait gros, quand on le décortique, avec le fait que je dis 3 fois 3
mais ça fonctionne bien si vous imposez un temps de réaction court.
Faut pas qu'il y ait une réflexion, faut qu'il y ait
une spontanéité de la personne en face de vous.
On efface tout ce qu'il y a dans votre tête, laissez vous aller, le but n'est pas d'aller contre moi
le but c'est de comprendre comment ça marche.
J'aimerais bien que vous ressentiez le fait que c'est bien ce nombre là qui arrive spontanément à l'esprit.
Vous allez maintenant penser à un nombre à 2 chiffres.
Les deux chiffres doivent être impairs et différents l'un de l'autre.
Maintenant !
Et vous devez être sur 35 ou 37, l'un des deux.
C'est là où il y a la petite nuance d'échec entre les deux.
Le fait de nous demander 2 nombres différents fait que notre cerveau va plus loin.
Le cerveau ne revient pas en arrière.
Donc il va chercher celui juste d'après, le 5 ou encore après le 7.
Il n'ira jamais au 9 et encore moins au 1.
Quand je m'en sers j'ai une petite technique qui ne vient pas de moi
qu'est beaucoup utilisée par les mentalistes, qui est de faire comme ça :
pensez à votre chiffre
Euh...Ah non...non non je pense que j'étais à côté..
C'est lequel ? Si la personne dit 37, vous dites ok c'est bon et si elle dit 35 vous pouvez dire "Ah j'aurais dû rester sur ma première impression"
Je sentais bien que c'était le 35, je me suis pas fait confiance bla bla bla...
Ces forcages numériques peuvent servir à plein de choses comme par exemple juste pour remporter un défi
ou pour prédire un nombre à l'avance
ou encore même pour forcer une page à quelqu'un.
Imaginons que je veux préparer une petite soirée à un spectacle, j'ai acheté des billets d'un spectacle
et je veux trouver une manière sympa de l'offrir à la personne, alors je lui trouve un gros bouquin
et je lui dis : Tiens, on va faire une petite expérience, pense à un nombre à 3 chiffres dans ta tête
mais attention les 3 chiffres doivent être impairs et identiques.
C'est bon, t'en as un ? Ouvre à la page à laquelle tu penses !
la personne ouvre à la page 333
et elle trouve les 2 places pour le concert.
Voici une des nombreuses applications possibles pour ce petit forcage numérique.
Merci de vous être peut-être réveillé avec moi
ou en tout cas d'avoir passé ce petit bout de dimanche ensemble.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, pensez à la gratifier d'un petit pouce en l'aiiiiir.
Si c'est pas déjà fait, pensez également à vous abonner à la chaîne
en cliquant sur le petit logo qu'il y a au dessus de moi.
C'était la vidéo 157 !
Le mental vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez-vous demain à 17h.
Ciao !